hustle while you wait so I talked about
this in a previous episode and it was
just kind of at the tail end of a video
and somebody asked me to expand on a
good little deeper so that's what this
video is for I think a lot of times as
entrepreneurs you can be waiting on
other people right if you're working on
a project of any size you're going to
involve other people other people need
to be a part of it and if if you're
we're going to project with nobody else
involved then it's probably such a small
project that it may not be worth your
time you know the big thing is involve
other people and so one of the
challenges of dealing with other people
is you got to wait for them you got to
wait for things to happen sometimes even
if you try your hardest and you're as
motivated as you can and you're
injecting inspiration other people you
still have to wait for them to get done
because you can't do everything yourself
and delays happen right life gets in the
way personal issues come up maybe they
go away on vacation or something happens
in their life or it's a holiday or
something something is going to happen
where you are just waiting for a
response you're waiting for something to
happen is one of the most frustrating
things as an entrepreneur because you
want to get stuff done now right you're
motivated you're excited you want to get
something done right now you'll stay up
till four in the morning finishing it
off and so you have two options and as
an entrepreneur you can either be the
person who says you know what I'm
waiting on this person so are the
tickety's you're gonna relaxed i'm gonna
chill for a little bit you know they're
not working hard so why should I work
hard or you're the kind of entrepreneur
who hustles just because you're waiting
on somebody else and there's a roadblock
there doesn't mean you can't take other
passes doesn't mean you can't continue
to hustle and work on that same project
but a different path or work on a
different project to move it forward
because the worst-case scenario is that
person drops the ball or says no or your
way mcklein and the deal doesn't happen
whatever whatever this area is and if
all you've been doing is waiting on that
person to get back to you when you
haven't done anything in the meantime to
that that one know what one drop project
could be crushing that could be the end
of your business but if you are doing
lots of other things to make sure you're
going to be successful then one drop
object that person doesn't get back to
you or delays till forever who cares you
got tons of other fish that you're
working on right now and so a lot of the
things that I work on involve other
people outside of my organization or I
can't you know kind of control a
timetable and schedule and so I will do
my best to move it as far along as
possible but whenever it's in their
hands I'm not just waiting on reply I'm
moving forward another pass there was an
example yesterday was my book writing
day I don't have a lot to write for the
book because i'm still waiting for
feedback from my publisher and it's kind
of frustrating because it's been over
two weeks since i heard back and i want
to get it out right like i want a hustle
i want to get it out i want to get
marketing this i'm tired of just being
in editing mode I want to start getting
this into people's hands is frustrating
right instead of just waiting and said
okay well what i do now it's book
writing day and i don't have anything to
do i started hustling so I wrote to my
publisher right I connect with the
publisher said hey I want to follow up
these are the most important issues
about that I feel we got to work on
let's get an answer I connected with my
literary agent and we talked about the
book and what needs to happen in my
views and where things are going right
now and what's gonna happen next I
connected with my main agent and talked
about the youtube channel and talked
about what's happening in the business
and the growth and how we can kind of
promote the book through the different
avenues once it's coming out I set up
meetings with other people so I set up
meetings with for youtubers who are
influencers who I made a personal
connection with who you know once the
book is out i can connect with them and
have them hopefully if they like it talk
about it to their audience and help
market it I connected with a video SEO
guy who when I create the content for
the books video content for the book we
can help optimize the content so it gets
out and people find the videos I
connected with a marketing consultant
who has launched a couple of online
channels apps a bunch of other things
just talking about the book what I'm up
to you getting her ideas and how market
and get it out I connected with two
owners of MCNS who have a broad reach
into a lot of different online
influencers who again once the book is
out and I have it in my hands I can give
to them if they like it it can help me
spread my reach
to a lot of other people and get get it
in their hands too I had my assistant do
some tasks for me I mentioned before
basically taking all of the content that
have been interviews or talking to other
people and compiling the documents that
i can send out to them and you made a
few mistakes on it so I corrected him
and asked him to do it again so working
on getting those packages that amigo to
myself it's him creating it and then I'm
going to send it off to the people and
get their feedback I connected with
Apple because I need to get some rights
for them to use a certain section of
content in the book and there's rules
around using their content not so
connected with them I've connected with
brian tracy and Michael Gerber who are
both kind of heroes and legends in the
entrepreneur space talking about what
they're working on and hopefully getting
their support to promote the book maybe
do an intro for the book showcase it
share it building a relationship I wrote
two more sections for the book that
we're kind of nagging at me and and from
feedback that I got from other people
felt like I needed to add a little bit
more content in so I addressed to the
issues of people kept coming back to
asking me questions I really like that
and then what happens when I do this and
so I added that into into the book as
well I think it's going to add a lot of
value I design a t-shirt I've been
working with designer on the t-shirt and
marketed that and that's going to be up
soon so pay attention and we might be
able have a teacher campaign related to
the book as well when that comes out and
the the advice and experience and kind
of launching t-shirt can help launch the
book as well and of course I spend a lot
of time in the YouTube comments I feel
like the YouTube community you guys are
one of the core reasons why I'm here who
is why I got the book deal now I'm going
to spread it and spread awareness for
the book and I think too many youtubers
ignore their audience and don't
participate in the comments and aren't
they're not seeing and just create
content and I think one of the strengths
of this channel is the feedback in the
community and the the love that happens
a lot of comments are negative on
YouTube China's words super positive
here and so I need to spend time in the
community to spend time every day in the
YouTube Trinity on believe nation and
our channel answering comments and
getting back to people and so that's a
productive use of time so I'm doing all
these things while I'm waiting for my
publisher to get back to me now when the
publisher gets back and has some ideas
and changes and i'll go and implement
those but if they don't that i'll be
hustling on other things and so
constantly hustling while you're waiting
to get feedback on something I'm not
just sitting around and waiting for
someone to get back to me I'm out moving
and you should be too because there are
those projects and your kind of mailing
it on few of them there's some things we
gon just wait on that guy and then you
take it easy you got to stop that
mentality ASAP and get right into
hustling on another project so answering
some of the questions that came in from
the last video Nathan was asking hey
Evan love your videos had a question for
you I find myself an analysis paralysis
awful and I'm trying to learn about
business related topics how do you know
what to absorb what the filter out when
you need advice that's very interesting
a comment for me for one whatever I'm
faced with the challenge I try to model
success I try to find someone who's
already done it and learn from them and
apply to my business i talked about how
Bill Gates saved my business I learned
stratagem Microsoft they were software
company I had a software company I want
the model at work for them and apply to
my company that's what helped save my
company and get me out of you know
making no money actually doing something
being successful and so that's become
kind of my default thinking anytime I
want to try to get better at something I
look at okay who can teach me who's
already done it and what lessons kind of
learn from them at the same time I also
try to just surround myself with
greatness as a general rule so the time
videos on my youtube channel the inter
press 0 series that I start the morning
with every day I often pick up different
lessons and different ways of thinking
that I may not have even had on my radar
but find interesting and I just like
seeing how great entrepreneurs and great
innovators and great thinkers and great
inventors I like seeing how they think
and I feel like if you surround yourself
with that enough a little bit of the
magic dust rubs off on you you get a
little bit smarter you think a little
bit differently and so I'll often
consume that content more with an aim of
being inspired then looking for a
specific strategy so it's both
approaches it's one like okay I need to
market my book who's
marketed books really well what can I
learn for them you know Ryan Holliday is
a master at he sent me some of his stuff
I'm gonna be meeting with him in austin
texas it looks a little bit and then
also just general inspiration baby
picture ideas stuff to kind of get the
juices flow him and then as a little
kind of side note on that i'll often
find that watching the same thing over
everything the same book again i take
something different from it so there are
some books and i might read a couple
times if you like that might watch
there's a you know great Steve Jobs
video on marketing that I have on the
channel that every time I watch it I
still take I can watch it a hundred
times plus i still take a little bit of
something new from it I think it just
depends on where you're at were you
where you're at in your kind of mental
frame of mind so both of those things a
lot of success for self intangible
you're looking to get and then create an
environment of greatness that builds you
up and inspires you to want to do
something big mrs. doodle journey wrote
in amazing content here I always
struggled with the idea of hiring people
I would like to check out up work never
heard of it before you mention it I do
have a question could you introduce us
to team I'd love to have a deeper look
into how many team members you have
including what their responsibilities
are so up work used to be odesk they're
probably better known as being owed a
stand-up work but it's a part of the
rebrand I've been a huge fan of them and
was a fan of odesk as well especially if
you have tasks that you don't need to
have somebody physically next to you in
an office to be able to do and so who's
on my team but we think we got a lot of
people on the team so I've Christina and
Sam hi the video editors who create a
lot of these videos there's Nina who's
my wife who answers a lot of the
comments on the channel and is in a lot
of the videos said the wife about
Caroline J reyez has been in a few of
the videos and there's a lot of kind of
high-level strategy and thinking and
empire building for the channel Ivan
does a lot of research for the channel
and is involved in the in the comments
Jasmina is my personal assistant mons or
does a lot of the marketing and
background information more for the
website within a YouTube channel mizzou
array and GT basically are all part of
my my website so they help run
marcom Ali is my programmer who runs the
program inside of my website Jen does a
lot of copywriting for the content
Morgan on the website than on the
YouTube channel Marion is my publisher
Nina is another Nina in DNA is my door
agent steve is my main agent Janney is
my media coach Stephanie my sister helps
run the investments that we make in
tequila which is funding businesses in
Africa ed is my server guy and does all
the work on our kind of backing for the
website rizal is my graphic designer so
making some of the icons and making the
t-shirts and some of the graphic work am
I missing anybody it's a lot a lot of
people I think we're up to 18 people
plus me on the team so 19 people i'm
looking to hire one more person now to
help me book a lot of the meetings and
hangouts and stuff that I'm doing in my
business so we'll be at 20 soon it's
getting to the point where it's it's a
lot to manage I don't know what point I
need to have like sub-layers I don't
like the idea of kind of losing I liked
the personal touches like the I like
knowing what people are up to me being a
direct report but I'm quickly becoming a
bottleneck in that process where I think
a lot more would happen if everything
didn't have to go through me and so I'm
delegating more responsibilities and at
some point we'll have to have layers
which I'm not looking forward to but I'm
also looking forward to because that
means the company's grown Julian Santa
got to come down to Texas we'll meet up
yeah I'll let you know so he's in austin
and i'm not sure when we're gonna do
that meet up I know when the book comes
out we'll probably do more tours and
going to different cities and all that
stuff but I'm gonna be meeting Ryan I
just gotta figure out the schedule it's
really on me he's ready to meet whenever
it's real I mean figure out when I'm
gonna go down I hate traveling it's part
of it I hate being away from here I feel
less productive there's so much it
happens on a day-to-day basis that I
feel you know I went to Madrid couple
weeks ago I came back for a few days and
I went to Orlando and a family trip it's
like I miss so much I feel so behind I
feel so disconnected from everything
that I'm doing that I don't like it so
it's on me I gotta get
to him we'll figure it out khalif II
wrote in hi Evan I want to know the
title of the book and what is the value
added for entrepreneurs and what is
different from other motivational person
develop materials so a lot of that is
still classified I haven't mentioned the
name of the book Jen knows it but but
it's not it's not a public yet and in
terms of the added value you know I
didn't really want to write this book I
wrote it because it didn't exist I wrote
it because I was trying to figure it out
and I had two thirds of it kind of in my
head as a blueprint for what I have done
but I didn't find anybody else who liked
this book has not been written and the
third section was me going out of
interviewing other companies who applied
similar principles that I've used and I
basically wrote the blueprint everybody
who has been involved in running their
business this way I just kind of figured
it out on their own but haven't there's
never been a manual to turn to do to
help them so I wish you didn't have to
write the book I wish it existed so I
could just follow it but you know like a
lot of great products it's it's formed
out of frustration right I started the
top 10 series because I I wanted to be a
consumer of it I didn't want to have to
create the region 6 a lot of work to
make those videos I just wanted to be a
consumer and enjoy it not happen to make
it but nobody else was doing it so I did
and so I'm not sure when the title is
gonna come out I'm sure once we get into
like marketing mode we're almost there
almost there got to still work with the
publisher on a few issues that we're
fighting over but we're almost there so
super exciting thank you guys for the
questions for those of you who leave a
comment in in the comments below for
next week's video if you have a thought
about how some are you wait if you have
a question about my book or the book
writing process leave in the comments
below and I'll answer to the next video
thank you guys so much for watching you
need to believe and i'll see you soon